y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola que tal saben cómo me llaman
me llaman el psicólogo del dolor
pero no bien pues de hecho os voy a
hablar un poquito
el dolor es el problema que ha traído de
cabeza a los profesionales de la salud
desde hace mucho tiempo
hay dos tipos de dolor
el dolor agudo
qué es el adaptativo y el dolor crónico
que no lo es tanto
hoy en día sabemos que el dolor por
investigaciones que se han hecho y demás
que el dolor se produce 100% en el
cerebro
por lo tanto el dolor
depende de uno mismo
fijaros también se sabe
que el dolor es una emoción
y las emociones se influyen mucho en el
manejo del dolor crónico
se entremezclan se potencian entre sí
yo os voy a contar
o
una metáfora que se llama
la metáfora de bienvenidos todos
y el invitado grosero para que
intentamos un poco de cómo va
las emociones con respecto al dolor
imaginemos
que estáis en la fiesta vais a organizar
la fiesta de vuestra vida en una ciudad
y ustedes soy los anfitriones
solo hay una regla
que se debe poner el cartel en la puerta
bienvenidos todos
al estar el cartel en la puerta
bienvenidos todo todo el mundo puede
entrar a la fiesta bien empieza la
fiesta y empieza a entrar invitados
empieza
a disfrutar a pasarla bien ya eso que en
un momento dado entra un invitado
crucero
maloliente
mal vestido
despeinado y empiezo a incordiar a los
demás invitados claro ustedes como
buenos anfitriones agarras a ese
invitado y lo sacáis a la calle claro en
el momento que lo sacáis a la calle como
hay un cartel en la puerta donde pone
bienvenidos todos el invitado a entrar y
vuelven cordial a los demás invitados
así una vez otra vez hasta que pensáis
decidís
dice bueno voy a agarrar
al invitado lo voy a meter en una
habitación pero claro al meter la
habitación tiene que estar en la puerta
pendiente para que no salga para que no
empieza a molestar a los demás invitados
mi pregunta es
estáis ustedes como anfitriones
verdaderamente disfrutando de la fiesta
o la estáis perdiendo
estáis perdiendo
que simboliza la fiesta
la vida que simboliza el invitado
grosero
las emociones negativas como por ejemplo
el dolor que simboliza los demás
invitados pues esas emociones positivas
que no le estamos prestando atención
porque porque vivimos detrás de esas
emociones negativas para poder sacarla
de nuestra fiesta
para poder sacarla de nuestra vida sin
darnos cuenta que hay otro tipo de
emociones en nuestra vida
diariamente tenemos emociones positivas
pero no le echamos cuenta la dejamos
pasar porque estamos completamente
prestándole atención a esas emociones
negativas y ya que hablamos de atención
esa atención es otro factor muy
importante para el manejo del dolor del
dolor crónico
fijaros
que como he comentado antes
cuando más intentamos ir detrás de esos
pensamientos negativos de esas emociones
negativas para echarla - se va se van de
nuestra cabeza por ejemplo
si yo digo
no pensar en un elefante azul
en vuestra mente hay un elefante azul
entonces no le echemos cuenta dejemos la
pensemos más en esos estímulos emociones
positivas porque la otra se va a ir solo
fijaron lo importante que es la atención
en el en el manejo del dolor crónico que
una persona
cuando tiene dolor crónico
cuando está pasando un rato agradable
con sus amigos con su familia
parece que le duele menos cierto
cuando está aburrida
cuando está enojada cuando está triste
parece que le duele más
porque el diagnóstico a sí mismo porque
porque le prestamos muchísima atención a
esos estímulos negativos que no dejamos
que nuestra mente se vayan porque cuanto
más va más vamos detrás de ese de ese
pensamiento de esas emociones menos se
van a verificar que en la atención
para el manejo de la atención hay dos
factores hay dos formas de manejar la
atención
con respecto al dolor crónico uno es la
atención manejo de la atención por
distracción es decir yo miro a un
estímulo positivo y por ende si yo le
presta atención a un estímulo positivo
le voy a prestar menos atención al
estímulo negativo por tanto la
percepción subjetiva del dolor es menor
y después hay otro factor que es
el manejo de la atención por la
imaginación
fijaros que la imaginación
es una arma terapéutica
increíble
es un arma que tenemos todos y cada uno
de nosotros
terapéutica increíble y no la utilizamos
hasta hoy en día de momento espero que
siga así no nos pueden controlar la
imaginación llegará el día en que bueno
nos pongan un chip y demás y sepan o de
que lo que estamos imaginando pero de
momento no las imaginaciones personales
de cada uno utilicemos la de forma
terapéutica para una mejor calidad de
vida sobre todas las personas con dolor
os cuento una anécdota de un colega que
estaba en en sevilla y estaba en un
hospital en la unidad de paliativos
entonces le dijo
un médico dice hablando con el colega de
isabel dice mira dice tengo un paciente
que le queda poco si está por morir
y bueno
no sé lo que le está pasando pero tiene
un picor
en vez de es cuando uno se va allá que
está a las puertas de irse lo que
intentan los médicos y todos los
profesionales la salud es que esos
últimos días sean los más agradables
posibles y me le comentó al compañero
dice no lo podemos conseguir dice porque
tiene un picor horrendo en el cuerpo muy
fuerte y el estado dando todo tipo de
medicamento pero el picor no se va
entonces colega éste le dijo dice bueno
en qué habitación está
dijo la habitación es un momento voy a
entrar
entra y se verá llegar a este paciente
tumbada en la cama se presenta y le dice
dice cierra los ojos
dice imagínate
qué estás en la playa
y todo tu cuerpo está cubierto de arena
la arena de la playa con el salitre pica
dice entonces imagínate que ese picor
que tienes en el cuerpo está causado por
esa arena de la playa porque tienes tu
cuerpo completamente cubierto
y ahora
voy a agarrar un pañuelo
te voy a ir sacando la arena y conforme
te voy sacando la arena de tu cuerpo el
picor va a ir desapareciendo
salió al rato no encontró con el médico
y su médico le dijo dice crisis
no le picó más
ya fue murió a los pocos días murió esa
persona pero no le picó más los últimos
días de su vida el paso de forma más
placentera fijaros el poder de la
imaginación
fijaros qué
lo que nos pasa y vuelvo a repetir con
el título de
de esta charla lo que nos pasa depende
de nosotros mismos no tenemos que
depender tanto de cosas externas
está bien
está bien cuando hay dolor crónico y hay
un pico de dolor crónico está bien tomar
medicamentos
pero hay que aprender
por ejemplo imaginaros
yo me levanto una mañana
estoy tumbado en mi sofá
lo que le gustaría a todo el mundo y
tengo una persona que me va a hacer los
mandados esa persona me va a comprar el
periódico me va a comprar la carne me va
a comprar el pago tranquilo
el sueño de todo pero en todo el mundo
era
claro pero llega un momento
que esa persona no está más
y yo salgo a la calle
y cuando salga a la calle miro para un
lado y no para otro y digo
donde se compra el periódico
donde se compra la carne
y el pan no sé por qué porque no aprendí
por qué por que delegue las cosas que
tenía que haber aprendido en un agente
externo
el agente externo es la medicación que
no estamos hablando que la medicación
esté mal no porque aquí lo que se trata
es de que las personas con este tipo de
dolencia lleven un tratamiento
multidisciplinar pero yo con esa persona
con ese chico que me hace los mandados
yo voy a acompañarlo con el comprar el
periódico voy con él a comprar la carne
voy con él a comprar
el pan y cuando esa persona no está más
yo sé dónde ir
igual pasa con el dolor con el cual pasa
con la medicación yo me tomo la
medicación cuando hay un pico de dolor
pero mientras me estoy tomando la
aplicación del dolor estoy aprendiendo
estrategias como el manejo de la
atención el manejo de las emociones
para intentar que la percepción del
dolor subjetiva sea menor porque ya
sabemos que el dolor se produce 100% en
el cerebro
claro
eso es lo que se intenta y lo que
intentamos es que la gente aprenda que
todas esas estrategias están dentro de
una de una persona
no hay ni que lo sé no hay personas que
sepan más ni que sepa menos simplemente
no conocen esas estrategias y por lo
tanto no las usa lo que hay que hacer
que la sepa fijaros que yo hice un
tratamiento de intervención psicológica
sobre el dolor crónico aquí en el
hospital heras
realice en un par de tratamientos
y en ese par de tratamiento bueno lo
hice en grupo de forma grupal y quise
en una jornada quise mostrar los
resultados que salieron unos resultados
magníficos entonces bueno de una jornada
y le pregunté a una serie de pacientes
si querían
dar su testimonio
la mayoría dijeron que sí y al final de
las jornadas los pacientes desarrollaba
su testimonio fijaros que había
pacientes que tomaban no sé si conocéis
la pregabalina
bueno que se tomaban 15 pregala 15
pregabalina a la semana
llegaron a tomarse tres a la semana
es una reducción bastante importante
incluso había pacientes que eliminaron
y yo me acuerdo que ha enseñado a lo
último cuando ya
estaba terminando la jornada y estaban
los pacientes terminando de comentarnos
su experiencia en todo el proceso del
tratamiento psicológico sobre el dolor
crónico una persona en el público que le
pregunto a una de las pacientes
y le dijo dice bueno y ahora
que no toma medicación
que toma usted
para su dolor
y ella contestó
tomo mejores decisiones
fijaros
eso es lo que se pretende tomar mejores
decisiones con respecto al dolor crónico
pero no solo en el dolor crónico sino en
la vida
porque porque la vida depende de
nosotros mismos nosotros somos los que
manejamos la vida no agentes externos
y eso lo que se pretende y sobre todo en
el dolor crónico que se tomen mejores
decisiones con respecto a esa medicación
vamos a ir acompañando con un
entrenamiento previo una enseñanza de
estrategia para empezar a manejar un
poco ese tipo de dolor porque porque el
dolor
depende de uno mismo sin duda muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]